[Applause]
my name's Samuel Leeds and on the
best-selling author of this property
book by low-rent hi and in this book I
explain why most people think that they
should pay off their mortgage as quickly
as possible and are scared to pull out
equity to grow their portfolio the
reason is is because we've been
programmed that debt is bad whereas an
actual fact there's two types of debt
there's good debt and there's bad debt a
mortgage is debt but if you take out a
mortgage or release equity to then go
and invest in more properties and you do
that properly and professionally and Wow
then actually that's good debt and it's
a very small thing to do
because most people see it as debt
whereas successful investors they see
that kind of mortgage that kind of
equity that's been released if they see
is leveraged most people their end goal
is to be debt-free
whereas successful investors their end
goal is not to be debt-free
daran goal is to be financially free and
to be wealthy I know that this video
might almost contradict some people's
core beliefs maybe your mom and dad have
always told you all your life don't go
into debt payoff you more we just
quickly as possible work hard
whereas this is a little bit different
thinking but what I want to say is I
want to ask you to be open-minded and
think rather than with your emotions
think with your logic as if you were
making a business decision rather than
seeing these properties as as homes see
them as investments also I am not
advised to give mortgage advice so I
would always recommend speaking to a
mortgage broker and attacks the
accountant before you take on any
business decisions in property I can
only speak from my experience but I'm
doing pretty well from property so here
goes so I want to give you a couple of
case studies now the first case today
I'm going to give you is of a lady who I
actually knew and she was absolutely
skint and she used to always tell me you
know I'm really skin I can't afford to
pay my kids now her property she had no
mortgage on it so she was debt-free
which is most people's dream but she was
skint
she wasn't financially free her property
was worth three hundred thousand pounds
i sat down with her over a coffee and we
worked out that if she refinanced
remortgaged her property she'd be able
to pull out seventy five percent
of the value of this property 75 percent
for three hundred thousand pounds is two
hundred and twenty-five thousand pounds
when you refinance a property like that
you don't pay tax on the money because
effectively it's a loan it's not profit
so that two hundred twenty-five thousand
pounds all of it she could then reinvest
into property and abuse that has just
down payments with that kind of money
you could buy at least four or five
properties suddenly making this lady
she's no longer debt free but she's now
financially free she's now making three
four thousand pounds passive income
every single month but she's got
properties whereby she's got mortgages
on them does he actually matter that
she's not debt free well if it's good
debt I don't believe that does matter
also sometimes people worry inside what
about the end of the term that when you
need to pay the debt off but if she
refinance is this house buys four other
houses is financially free lives a long
happy life of good cash flow and passive
income at the end of the term when she
comes to pay off the mortgages the
chances are that the properties are
gonna have gone up considerably in value
on average properties double every ten
years in the UK now you can't
necessarily bank on it but that's what
generally happens so at the end of the
term when she's an old lady she's got
two options she can either option number
one sell off all the properties pull all
her deposit monies out and then she's
lived a life where she's been
financially free and now she's got this
money to live on invest in spend well if
she wants to do or number two is
depending on what the banks say she
could refinance again or she could sell
off one property and then with the
profit she could pay off the other
mortgages the bottom line is the world
is their oyster because she's used her
money smart to leverage and she's
focused on being wealthy and being
financially free instead of being some
wine lid and just trying to be debt-free
so if you've got a home that you live in
and you were equity it makes sense in my
opinion to refinance it and then invest
and grow a larger property portfolio let
me give you another case today let's say
you buy a property for one hundred
and pounds and this is a bike to let
property so you're buying this as an
investment you put down 25,000 pounds of
deposit you've got a mortgage of 75,000
pounds rather than trying to think for
this investment property I need to pay
off that seventy five thousand pounds as
quickly as possible that's not smart
the smart thing is to think number one
how can i generate as much cash flow as
possible from this property
maybe you'll rent it out by the room and
get more rent maybe you'll pay minimum
interest-only payments to increase your
cash flow that's smart
maybe you'll do things to the property
which will increase the value that's
smart so let's say after a few years
your property's now gone up and it's now
worth 150 thousand pounds now I think
the smart thing to do will be to
refinance that property how do you do
that I wouldn't usually recommend
speaking to a mortgage broker rather
than going straight to a bank because if
you go straight to a bank that Bank is
gonna offer you their best rights and
their best terms whereas if you go to a
broker although you might have to pay
the broker a small fee they'll go to
hundreds of banks and they'll get the
best return the best rights the best
type of loan the best type of mortgage
for you based on your terms rather than
you just go into one person also if
you've ever been declined a mortgage but
you've just gone straight to your bank
and they've said we can't give your
mortgage I'm sorry or we can't give you
a loan I'm sorry then the best thing to
do is go to a broker because just
because that bank couldn't give you a
mortgage does not mean by any stretch of
the imagination that no bank well so
you've bought a house for 100 it's now
worth 150 your mortgage outstanding is
seventy five thousand pounds if you go
to a broker and you say hey please can
you fit refinance this property what
will happen is there'll be a lender a
bank they will relook at the property
they will give a new valuation and if
they agree and say yeah this house is
now worth 150 thousand pounds
they will then offer to lend you 75% of
the new value so 75% of 150 thousand
pounds is one hundred and twelve
thousand and five hundred pounds so
they'll say we can now lend you one
hundred and twelve thousand and five
hundred pounds on this house now with
that
with that new mortgage you're going to
need to pay off the old mortgage which
is 75 thousand pounds which is going to
leave you with a difference with a
profit of thirty seven and a half
thousand pounds now that money about
thirty seven and a half thousand pounds
you don't need to pay tax on that it's
tax-free because unless you've sold the
property and made that money when you've
sold it then that's taxable because
that's capital appreciation so you'll
pay capital gains tax but if you
refinance it and get the cash from the
refinance technically that's not profit
it's just another loan so with that
thirty seven and a half thousand pounds
what are you gonna do well of course
you're gonna use that for a deposit on
another house the little bit extra
interest payments because you've made
the loan a bit bigger that you're going
to have to pay on property a I'm going
to be more than covered by property B
because you're gonna have a whole new
house with whole new tenants which means
that your cash flow is going to
significantly increase on a
month-by-month basis and because you've
now got two houses to investment
properties as they both continue to
increase
you've got more leverage so it just
makes sense if you want to be wealthy
and if you want to get good cash flow if
you use this strategy let's say you're
thirty years old if you're a thirty year
old person and you buy your first
property and you keep refinancing it as
it goes up if you play your cards right
you're a little bit smart there's no
reason why you won't be able to buy over
your lifetime let's save all the time is
65 twenty properties now some people say
but if you do that and you buy twenty
properties you're really highly
leveraged you can have to pay off the
mortgage at some point at the end of the
turn you're going to be left with all
this debt and that scares some people so
what would I say to that let's look at
the end goal let's look at the end term
so if you do this and you buy twenty
properties let's say each property
conservatively is going to be giving you
a profit of five hundred panema
depending on the properties it could be
more income be less and let's say that
these properties by the time you're 65
let's say they're worth two hundred
thousand pound each so you've got twenty
properties they're all worth two hundred
thousand pounds
you don't own these properties outright
you have 75 percent that the bank
and you only own 25% that means that
your property portfolio is worth 4
million you own 25% of that which is 1
million pounds so you are a cash
millionaire you're a millionaire and
you've got 20 properties making you 5
into Panama Beach you make in 10,000
pound profit a month you making 10 grand
a month you're a millionaire but you've
now got to pay these properties off what
do you do well again you've got
different choices you could pay off one
or two and then use that to them pay off
the more views on the other you can
refinance again or you could just if you
wanted to sell up tight you million quit
and then do whatever you want the bottom
line is debt is not bad
unless it's bad debt and the thing that
freaks me out is that the banks will say
to you property investing is risky the
schools will say property investing is
risky debt is bad but then they'll
happily lend you money to get married or
to go on holiday or to have an extension
to your house but then we tell you that
property investing is risky that's my
thoughts on the matter all I've done
this myself I've grown quite a large
property portfolio and I don't own the
properties outright I do get mortgages
when will I start paying their mortgages
off I guess when it gets to a point
where you've got more money than you
know what to do with and your property
portfolio is so huge and you might just
stop paying off properties for fun but
while you're growing while you're
striving to be financially free don't
worry about being debt for it just use
your desk smart and I wish you all the
best in your success I hope the helped
please do comment your thoughts below
don't forget to smash that like button
and if you haven't already please do
share and subscribe to the channel and
I'll see you next time
[Music]